[Music]
next gas is a comedian who's the co-host
of the double-date podcast and to be
seen live at comedy on state in Madison
Wisconsin July 11th through the 13th
please welcome the very funny
Shane Moss thank you guys it's nice to
be back I love being a comedian this is
an amazing job to have the longest job
that I had before this I worked for four
years at a Furniture Factory in
Wisconsin where I'm from
I worked there with a bunch of Mexicans
and a bunch of racists so that was an
interesting dynamic racist people if
you're white they just tend to assume
that you're just going to be on board
with whatever horrible rants that they
want to go on it's very uncomfortable so
I'll be in the break room just kind of
hanging out minding my own business and
all of a sudden some guy come barging in
Stan Mexicans are taking all our jobs
then in the next breath he'd be like and
why don't they learn to speak the
language um why do you want them taking
more of your jobs you're a miserable
lazy bigot ooh nobody likes English is
the only thing you have going for you
believe me they're taking all our jobs
well that's quite convenient for me
jobs are my least favorite thing about
life I hate jobs that's why I do this
silly crap no you don't understand Shane
these Mexicans they come in here they
bring all these drugs into our country
hold on a minute so what you're telling
me is that the Mexicans they're gonna
come here they're gonna bring me drugs
and do my job
oh dear I think we're gonna need a lot
more Mexicans kind of reminds me of the
Gaeta Bates everyone's all worried so
the gays are the root of all that if
we're honest with ourselves is that a
bunch of straight guys have a problem
with gay men and why because they don't
have sex with women that's more women
for the rest of us that's amazing news I
wish I were the only straight man on
earth do you have any idea how amazing
my life would be there would be women
flying from around the globe you
understand there be a wine outside my
house miles long every day would be a
Miss Universe pageant on my penis
as hard as it is to get a woman you like
you're worried about what gay men are
doing if anything straight guys you
should be upset at lesbians they're
taking perfectly good vaginas right off
the market
not some bull thanks I mean to be
political out I don't care if you're
democrat or republican I don't know
anything about health care or finance or
I'd have health care and finances I'm
not preaching gay tolerance either by
the way I find that weird tolerance
insulting oh I tolerate you
oh I tolerate your behavior that I don't
actually agree with how about
indifference who cares what anyone does
in their bedroom I don't want some
government guy with a clipboard in my
bedroom
monitoring my every move I mean it might
be cool the first couple times hey buddy
check this once these tries tell me what
I can't do well screw up cuz I'm not
even that kinky of a guy but I'll mix it
up from time to time my girlfriend and I
recently we experimented with a little
bit of hot wax and I was fun seems kind
of mild to me but who knows is that
gonna be illegal I don't know I made a
little candle in her but now I'm going
to jail
really me the one guy trying to bring
manufacturing back to the US
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]